منذ نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه كان
التنافس في سوق التسلح بين المعسكريين
الشرقيه والغربيه بعض الدول تبنت العقيده
العسكريه الشرقيه واعتمدت في تسليحها على
منظومات سوفيتيه بالكامل على الجانب الاخر
دول اخرى تبنت العقيده العسكريه الغربيه
واعتمدت هي الاخرى في تسلحها على منظومه
عسكريه امريكيه
لكن الان ومع كل هذه المتغيرات العسكريه
والاستراتيجيه التي طرات على العالم منذ
انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي وسولا الى الحرب
في اوكرانيا كيف تتعامل الدول مع هذه
المتغيرات ولماذا تلجا الان بعض الدول الى
تنويع مصادر تستحياء هذا ما سنتعرف عليه
الان مع الاستاذ رياض العسكري لبرنامج
عسكري استاذ رياض اولا اهلا بك معنا في
هذه الفقره ما الفرق بين العقيده العسكريه
الغربيه والعقيده العسكريه الشرقيه وكيف
اثرت هذه العقيده على شكل ال- ال- الاسلحه
التي يتم انتاجها في المستقبل
العقيد العسكريه الغربيه ان شاهدنا
الحراميه الثانيه
المتمثله باداء الحرب القوات الامريكيه
والالمانيه
ينتميان للمعسكر الغربي كان هناك المناوره
السريعه الحرب الخاطفه الاندفاع السريع في
خطوط العدو استخدام الكبير لقوات الجويه
في حينها كان هناك اتكال كبير على قوه
النيران البريه اا من مدرعات من مدافع كان
هناك اندفاع بهذا الشكل مع عقيده الارض
المحروقه همم اعتماد على ضرب عمق العدو
المنشات المدنيه لافقاد العدو اا لتاثير
على الناحيه النفسيه والقدره القتاليه
للعدو استمرت هذه العقيده في مرحله همم ما
يسمى الحرب البارده شاهدنا هناك تركيز همم
بناء منظومات صاروخيه صواريخ بالستيه همم
بشكل كثير الدبابات بشكل كثيف من الجانب
همم الروسي
والاليات المصفحه
للسيطره على الارض لعمليه التقدم في اطار
الحلقه الارض المحروقه مع ايضا تركيز على
مبدا حرب العصابات حرب الثوار هذا كان
اساسي لدى الشيوعيين واستمر حتى اليوم
لذلك نرى
الكلاشنكوف هو السلاح المفضل دائما الثوار
في جميع حركات الثوره التي شهدها العالم
منذ منذ الحراميه الثانيه حتى اليوم
السلاح الموسيطر الاول المفضل لدى الحركات
الثوريه اين مكان حول العالم هذا ياتي من
صنع هذا السلاح بهذا الهدف وربما نفهم هذا
في المستقبل من شكل الاسلحه التي تنتج
الان من روسيا وكذلك على الجانب الاخر من
اوروبا والولايات المتحده بانه الغربي
يركز على اسلحه دقيقه ومتطوره ولديها قدره
على اصابه الهدف بدقه بينما تركز روسيا
على اسلحه ثقيله ولديها قدره مريقه اكثر
يعني شاهدنا في تطورات الاساسيه لن لنقل
منذ حرب افغانستان همم اجتياح السوفيت
اللي افغانستان ما هو حتى اليوم شاهدنا
كيف
استخدم الروس سلاح الجو حينها لم يكن بهذا
الكفاءه خاصه عندما قام الامريكيون بتقديم
صواريخ ستينجا فشاهدنا تاخر التكنولوجيا
الروسيه في ما يخص قوه الجويه
تقدم او التفوق الغربي في التركيز على
القوه الجويه بدا الحربيه الثانيه واستمر
حتى اليوم همم في الحروب العربيه
الاسرائيليه الشهاده دائما هناك تفوق جوي
لجلب اسرائيل ليس لسوء اداء الطيران العرب
انما التكنولوجيا
الغربيه
لاحقا عندما قام في انفسهم بقياده
الطائرات ان كان في افغانستان او حتى
اخيرا في اوكرانيا مع وجود سلاح الدفاع
جوي متقدم عند الاوكرانيين شاهدنا عدم
قدره روسيا على السيطره على الاجواء في
اوكرانيا كما المشاكل التي واجهتها روسيا
في السيطره على الارض خلال حرب افغانستان
وبالتالي التفوق الغربي التكنولوجي في
مجال القوات الجويه والدفاع الجوي جدا
ملحوظ ومهم ومقارنه مع معسكر الشرقي استاذ
رياض هناك دائما على مدى سنوات دول اعتمدت
على تسريحات على الدول الغربيه على الجانب
الاخر هناك دول اخرى اعتمدت على تصليحها
على الاتحاد السوفيتي في السابق والان على
روسيا لكن الان في المنطقه العربيه تحديدا
وفي الشرق الاوسط وعدد كبير من دول العالم
باتت تنوع من مصادر همم هنا كمان يحصل على
اسلحه من الغرب هناك من يصلح على اسلحه من
الصين يعني دول كثيره الان بتعتمد على هذا
التنوع في مصادر التسيح لماذا تلجا الدول
لهذه الاست هناك
عاملان اساسيا في قرار الدوله او الجيش
عقيده قتاليه او نوع تسلح اولا القرار
السياسي يكون اقرب لاي جهه جهه المنشا
السلاح
الاخر هو المصادر الماليه في الجيوش
المصدر المالي او القوه الماليه للشراء
والتحديث هو ما يقرر اي سلاح تشتريه هذه
الدوله عند وجود موارد مالي ماليه تستطيع
الدوله الحصول على السلاح
الحديث
والسمين وان كانت متوفره بشكل كبير تستطيع
ان تنوع هناك النظريه النظريه تقول انه
يجب اعتماد مصدر واحد منشا واحد للتصالح
لان هذا يمكن همم الجيش من الحفاظ على
ميزانيه منخفضه لان هناك مصدر واحد التنوع
في التسلق يعني عليك ان ترصد اموال لنو
طائره للذخيره الخاصه بها لقطع الغيار
خاصه بها لتدريب الجنود والطيارين عليها
وبالتالي
يتضاعف حجم همم
المصدر انما الميزه المهمه الايجابيه
لتنوع المصدر هو في حال كان هناك مشاكل
سياسيه مع احد الجهات المورده لهذه السلاح
لا لا يضع الجيوش رهينه
الاخر ولكن الان هناك عقب فيما يتعلق
بالدول التي اعتمدت على اسلحه روسيه همم
او اسلحه سوريا في السابق وعلى روسيا في
الوقت الحالي الان روسيا عليها عقوبات
غربيه وهذه العقوبات جزء كبير منها تطال
شركات تصنيع الاسلحه في روسيا كيف ستعامل
هذه الدول وهل انا الاوان لها ان تبحث عن
بدائل للاسلحه الروسيه هذه الدول ستواجه
مشاكل غلط هذه الحرب
اما ان تلجا لتطوير
همم يعني قدرات ذاتيه من همم تصنيع قطع
غيار ذخائر لما تملكه من اسلحه هذه حاليا
او تلجا لمصادر لديها مصانع قريبه من
المنشا الشرقي مثلا الصين قد تكون المداد
المهم للدول التي تستخدم الاسلحه الروسيه
لانه هناك تقارب كبير معظم الاسلحه تصنع
في الصين اليوم هي اصلها روسي وبالتالي
تستطيع الصين ان تملا الفراغ حاليا كوريا
الشماليه قد تستطيع ان تبدا عليها عقوبات
فبالتالي تكون الصين هي البلد المهم هناك
بعض الدول الاوروبيه كانت سابقا في
المعسكر الشرقي تستطيع ايضا ان تملا
الفراغ مثل فولندا بلغاريا ولديها مصانع
تصنع ذخائر لاسلحه روسيه وبالتالي هي
تستطيع ايضا ان تملا هذا الفراغ